not living up to our potential but and I
might dispute whether we are an empire
or not I know there's a big debate about
that I don't I don't think we need to go
there but we we need to be leaving in a
different way we need to be leading
let's put it that way we aren't we are
not leading the world as it is we've
really been the big detractor in the
international system and if we want to
continue to thrive we have to lead in a
different way and we have to get our act
together at home and I think those are
the two real key things that we have to
do differently but the issue of of
whether we are declining is semantics in
some ways to me I mean if you if you
think of power as a relative concept
then of course as as China and India and
Russia and even Japan and Europe gain
more power we're going to have
relatively less than they do but I don't
think that's the key question I think
the key question is so what does that
matter for the United States how will
that affect American security and
prosperity and our way of life because
the fact is that the rise of these other
powers can actually be good to the
United States in many ways
we are for example our security they can
be our security partners the two threats
that are able to kill large numbers of
Americans soon are terrorists armed with
a nuclear weapon and contagious disease
lethal contagious disease something like
the avian flu those are the only two and
if you look at those two the rise of
these other powers can help us with
those threats they face those threats as
well and for example on terrorism we
rely on Scotland Yard and on the police
and Hamburg to be arresting suspects and
I think there are Americans alive today
because of those efforts China allows
our inspectors and their ports to screen
shipping containers for nuclear devices
before they reach our shores India has
deep expertise in Islamic extremist
groups that we now need because these
groups are now targeting the United
States and even Russia we have a very
you know cantankerous relationship with
Russia at the moment but they are a key
security partner in keeping nuclear
materials out of the hands of terrorists
and on disease I mean the best
protection against it you know disease
here in the United States is a strong
public health system in China so on
these on the issues that are that the
most direct security threats to United
States these other countries are really
our partners and even on economics you
know they there's a lot of dislocation
that happens because of globalization
and because of trade with these
countries but there are ways in which
their prosperity is it is pretty
directly linked to our prosperity
I think that things could be potentially
different if we have a Democratic
president and the Democratic Congress
maybe not as different as we would hope
but I think they will be different for
example the climate the climate crisis
is a good example I do think that a
Democratic president with the Democratic
Congress behind him or her we'll be able
to actually push that issue in a way
that hasn't we haven't been able to so
far and I think on other issues as well
universal health care for example I
think I'd have more hope for universal
health care going forward under under
that kind of a scenario and a more
robust and renewed social safety net to
empower our workers and to have them
feel less anxious about the about
globalization I think I think all those
things could be different in Canada
hundred Democratic administration I
think that the basic structure you know
is dictated by the Constitution and
that's going to stay in place but in
terms of changing how the NSC and the
State Department and homeland security
relate to each other I do think we need
changes there we getting back to earlier
discussion about domestic and
international I mean right now the
government is still stove-piped in that
way as well and we have to be able to
you know bring these different policy
bodies together in order to forge policy
that actually makes sense you know
toward these powers that are so complex
and affect our lives in so many
different ways security and prosperity
and food safety and climate and North
Korea and across the board